Courtney
Courtney no not quite Courtney
that would be Khloe Kardashian who just
taught a master class on how to tell the
difference between her and her eldest
sister Courtney after the paparazzi got
them confused
on Monday Coco posted this message
dripping in sarcasm to her insta story
writing that she totally understands how
they look like identical twins so she's
hopeful her presentation will help the
people that were screaming her sister's
name
this one's for you I'm gonna figure it
all out I promise you close shares this
snap of her sis explaining that she's
fabulous gorgeous hysterical so she
understands the confusion tip number one
for telling them apart Chloe says court
is a brunette 99 of the time while she
is a blonde 99 of the time exactly tip
number two court is quite tiny measuring
five feet one inches tall while the good
American founder is 5 feet 10 inches
yeah Chloe says that nine inch
difference is a dead giveaway what is
wrong with people so to recap Chloe is
blonde Courtney is brunette and Chloe is
much taller than Courtney tip number
three Chloe says her eyes are lighter
than quartz but the confusion is nothing
new Chloe says people mix them up on a
daily basis multiple times a day not
even the Elvis officiant at Courtney and
Travis Barker's Las Vegas wedding could
get it right right in your first names
Chloe Travis
[Music]
hi Travis
it's Courtney Courtney I'm so hi Travis
taking Courtney to be my wife
she's gonna literally die they won't
make good makeup Chloe jokes that she
understands the resemblance between them
is uncanny that their beauty is
identical and only their mother can tell
them apart but she hopes her
presentation helps those that have been
confused for over 20 years
of course we'll see lots of the sisters
on the upcoming third season of their
Hulu series which premieres May 25th I
think that you have a real insight not
only you know what you see in the press
or whatever but what's really happening
behind the scenes on Tuesday Kim stopped
by the Today Show and said this season
when he wasn't an easy one to film out
of filming Keeping Up with the
Kardashians or the Kardashians this
season was probably my most emotional
and frustrating internally with family
that I haven't really seen or
experienced before I'm really confused
how this narrative came into her head
like I couldn't have been more mindful
people think that's a misunderstanding
it's not
it's who she is to her core and
according to Chloe fans can expect all
the drama I wish I could tell you this
is going to be a mild relaxing Serene
season
it's not
foreign